HE WILL EXPLAIN.
BUT FIRST, A LAND OF RISK
TAKERS.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
ALL OF US IN THE INGRAM
HOUSEHOLD WERE LIKE MOST
AMERICANS, DISAPPOINTED WHEN
THIS AFTERNOON SPACEX
LAUNCH SCRUB DUE TO STORMS IN
THE AREA.
MISSION CONTROL DECIDED THE RISK
WAS TOO GREAT TO TAKE A CHANCE.
SO THEY RESCHEDULED FOR SATURDAY
AFTERNOON WHEN THEY WILL MAKE A
NEW SET OF RISK CALCULATIONS
BEFORE TAKEOFF IS ATTEMPTED
AGAIN.
NOW, THIS GOT ME THINKING ABOUT
RISK ASSESSMENT THAT WILL MAKE
EVERY DAY.
DECISIONS BIG AND SMALL THAT
HAVE ENORMOUS CONSEQUENCES ON
OUR HEALTH, OUR WELL-BEING, OUR
INNER SENSE OF HARMONY, OUR
FINANCES.
WALKING OUT OF THE HOUSE EVERY
MORNING INSTANTLY EXPOSES US TO
RISK.
STEPPING INTO A VEHICLE, BUYING
A STOCK, EVEN ORDERING IN A
RESTAURANT, ALL INVOLVED AT A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF RISK.
SO YOU THINK ABOUT IT, IF WE
NEVER TAKE RISK, WE NEVER MOVE
BEYOND THE STATUS QUO.
WE NEVER INNOVATE.
WE NEVER IMPROVE.
WE NEVER LEARN.
WE NEVER GROW.
NOW WHILE THE CORONAVIRUS IS
NOVEL, OUR APPROACH TO IT LIKE
OUR APPROACH TO EVERY CHALLENGE
ALSO INCLUDES RISK.
LETTING CITIZENS MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS DETERMINE THEIR OWN
DESTINY, THAT IS THE HALLMARK OF
OUR FREE SOCIETY.
YET TIME AND AGAIN, THE LEFT HAS
MOVED TO LIMIT INDIVIDUAL
CHOICES ON VERY PERSONAL
DECISIONS.
FROM WHETHER YOU CAN BUY A
FIREARM TO WHETHER YOU CAN EVEN
EDUCATE YOUR OWN CHILDREN AT
HOME.
TO THE TYPE OF CAR YOU DRIVE.
TO YOUR RIGHT TO SPEAK FREELY ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
NOW, OTHER THAN PUSHING FOR
ABORTION OR MAY BE MARIJUANA
MAYBE LIBERALS TODAY HAVE BECOME
VERY ILL LIBERAL.
AND THEY ARE ARGUMENT AGAINST
YOUR EXERCISING, YOUR OWN FREE
WILL IS ALWAYS THE SAME.
THEY CLAIM THAT YOU ARE PUTTING
YOURSELF AND OTHERS AT RISK.
AND THEN THEY USE SCARE TACTICS
AND SOMETIMES SKEWED STATISTICS
TO PUSH THEIR AGENDAS FROM GUN
CONTROL TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND RATHER THAN PASSING ACTUAL
LEGISLATION, THEY WILL OFTEN DO
THIS THROUGH EMERGENCY DECREES
OR OTHER EXECUTIVE ACTION.
NOW INDEED, THIS IS A PATTERN OF
BLUE STATE GOVERNORS AND RADICAL
MAYORS DURING COVID-19.
THEY SIMPLY DON’T TRUST THEIR
OWN CITIZENS AT A TIME WHEN THEY
SEEM TO RELISH PUNISHING THEM.
SPEAK WITH THE POLITICAL RALLY
LIKE THAT WHERE PEOPLE ARE NOT
WEARING MASKS IN CLOSE QUARTERS
THEY ARE TOUCHING ONE
ANOTHER, YOU KNOW THAT IS
PRECISELY WHAT MAKES THIS KIND
OF DISEASE DRAGGED OUT.
IN THIS SITUATION WHERE I MIGHT
ACTUALLY HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
EXTENDING STAY-AT-HOME ORDERS.
>> AND SHE DID EXTEND THE
STAY-AT-HOME ORDER, ALSO
ANDREW CUOMO, HE NEEDLESSLY
PUSHED FOR THIS COMPLEX PLAN
CALLED NEW YORK FORWARD.
IT REQUIRES ONLY SEVEN METRICS
TO GET TO CHANGE ONE REOPENING
IF YOU CAN BELIEVE IT.
AND THIS AS A CITY IS LITERALLY
AND FIGURATIVELY DYING.
MAYOR de BLASIO STILL HAS A
PLAN TO REOPEN NEW YORK CITY
RESTAURANTS AND BARS.
>> SO WE ARE GOING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW AND WHEN WE CAN REOPEN BARS
AND RESTAURANTS.
HOW MUCH OUTDOORS WILL PLAY A
CRUCIAL ROLE IN THAT.
I THINK IT IS A VERY ENCOURAGING
POSSIBILITY TO LEAN TO THE
OUTDOORS.
BUT EVEN THAT, WE HAVE A LOT TO
FIGURE OUT IN TERMS OF SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
FACE COVERINGS, PROTOCOLS, AND
WHAT AMOUNT OF CAPACITY YOU CAN
CREATE THAT WOULD MAKE IT
WORTHWHILE.
>> Laura: NOW NINE WEEKS INTO
THIS, THEY STILL HAVEN’T THOUGHT
THIS THROUGH?
NOW, I TRUST AND HE RAN FROM
RANDOM RESTAURANT OVER THAT GUY
IN A DAY.
I WOULDN’T TRUST HIM TO DRIVE AN
ICE CREAM TRUCK FOR GOODNESS
SAKE.
AND NOTICE HOW NONE OF THE RULES
AT THESE POWER CRAZED GOVERNORS
OR MAYORS FORCED ON YOU EVER
APPLY TO THEM.
THE LATEST FRAUD IS NEW MEXICO’S
GOVERNOR MICHELLE LUJAN GRISHAM.
HERE IS WHAT SHE’S BEEN UP TO.
WELL K OR Q NEWS 13 HAS LEARNED
IN APRIL WHEN SHE ORDERED
NONESSENTIAL BUSINESSES TO SHUT
DOWN AND LECTURE ALL MEXICANS TO
STAY HOME A NONESSENTIAL
BUSINESS OPENED UP SO SHE COULD
BUY JEWELRY AND HAVE IT
DELIVERED TO HER.
AGAIN, RULES FOR THE BUT NOT FOR
MEAN.
AND OF COURSE, SHE IS DEFENDING
HER HYPOCRITICAL CONDUCT WITH A
SPOKESPERSON SAYING "THE STORE
WAS NEVER OPENED AND A GOOD SAFE
PROCESS WAS FOLLOWED."
THE GOVERNOR HAS, OF COURSE, AND
POKED HER PURSE IT --
PROFESSIONAL TO PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURES ENACTED DURING THE
DURATION OF THE PANDEMIC.
SHE IS ON THE SHORT LIST OF
BIDEN POTENTIAL VP PICK, BY THE
WAY.
FAR AWAY IN HAWAII, STATEMENT, I
KID YOU NOT COME A ONLY 17 COVID
DEATHS.
DEMOCRAT GOVERNOR DAVID DOESN’T
TRUST HIS OWN PEOPLE TO MANAGE
THEIR OWN COVERT RISK.
HE HASN’T EVEN FINALIZED A PLAN
TO END HIS STUPID ENTER ISLAND
QUARANTINE.
I WAS SAYING THIS EARLIER THEO
LOJA STATE WILL SAY A LOW HOT AS
IN GOODBYE TO OF RECOVERY IF IT
DOESN’T WAKE UP SOON.
"ANGLE" ISN’T SAYING THE
CORONAVIRUS SHOULDN’T BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY.
WE TAKE IT VERY SERIOUSLY.
THE HUMAN TOLL, THE ECONOMIC
TOLL AND THE 1,000 TESTS.
IT IS HEARTBREAKING.
AND THE ENORMITY OF IT, IT IS
SOMETIMES HARD TO TAKE IN.
BUT WHAT WE ARE SEEING AT THE
SAME TIME IS THE STATES THAT
HAVE GIVEN MORE TRUST TO THEIR
OWN CITIZENS ARE DOING BETTER
THAN THE STATES WHO TREAT THEIR
CITIZENS LIKE SCHOOLCHILDREN.
WE BELIEVE THAT PASTORS OF THE
LOCAL CHURCH ARE GOING TO DO, I
THINK, THEIR BEST TO BALANCE
THEIR DUTY TO GOD WITH THE DUTY
THEY HAVE THE SAFETY OF THE
CONGREGATION.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT LOCAL LIKE
HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL COACHES
WILL BALANCE THEIR DUTY TO THE
SCHOOLS WITH THE DUTY THAT OUR
PLAYERS AND PRESERVING THEIR
HEALTH.
WE BELIEVE THAT LOCAL RESTAURANT
TOURS, YES WE WILL FIGURE OUT
HOW TO BEST BALANCE THEIR
DESIRE TO STAY PROFITABLE WITH
THEIR DUTY TO KEEP CUSTOMERS AND
WORKERS AS SAFE AS POSSIBLE.
LOOK, IF THEY SLIP UP, THAT IS
WHERE THE FREE MARKET COMES IN.
THEY WILL EITHER BE SUED, THEY
WILL GO OUT OF BUSINESS, OR
BOTH.
BUT LET’S FACE IT.
SOME ELECTED OFFICIALS NEVER
LIKED THE FREE MARKET THAT MUCH.
THEY PREFER TO KEEP A LOT OF YOU
DEPLORABLES LOCKDOWN AND AFRAID.
THEY WANT YOU MAST, NOT JUST
DURING THE VIRUS, BUT UNTIL THE
END OF TIME.
BECAUSE REMEMBER, YOU WILL
ALWAYS BE ANOTHER POTENTIAL
VIRUS LURKING OUT THERE
AROUND THE CORNER.
AND DON’T YOU WANT TO PROTECT
OTHERS?
WHAT KIND OF MONSTER ARE YOU IF
YOU DON’T WEAR A MASK FOREVER?
NOW THEY TALK ABOUT UNITY IN
CRISIS.
WHILE THEY TURN NEIGHBOR AGAINST
NEIGHBOR, REPORTING ON EACH
OTHER FOR A VIOLATION.
BUT THE TRUTH IS, THEY DON’T
BELIEVE IN THEIR OWN RULES
BECAUSE IF VIRGINIA
GOVERNOR RALPH NORTHAM WAS
REALLY CONVINCED THAT WEARING
MASKS WILL SAVE LIVES, HE WOULD
HAVE WORN A MASK AT THE BEACH
LAST WEEKEND.
AND IF ILLINOIS GOVERNOR J.B.
PRITZKER REALLY LOCKDOWN
MEASURES WERE SO GREAT IN HIS
STATE, HE WOULD NOT LET HIS
FAMILY TRAVEL AND RISK THEIR
LIVES TO GO TOO RISKY, DANGEROUS
FLORIDA AND WISCONSIN.
AND IF MISSION -- MICHIGAN
GOVERNOR WITMER SAID TRAVELING
UP NORTH WOULD PUT FOLKS IN JEOP
THERE HER HOBBY WOULD NOT HAVE
TRAVELED THERE TO TAKE HIS VOTE
OUT OF STORAGE.
BUT ALL OF THESE LOCKDOWN
GOVERNORS WERE WILLING TO TAKE
RISKS.
THEY DEPRIVE THEIR OWN CITIZENS
FROM TAKING.
BUT THE RISKS ARE BEING TAKEN
ANYWAY.
WHAT AM I TALKING ABOUT?
INVESTORS TODAY CONTINUE TO BET
ACTUAL MONEY ON THE GREAT
AMERICAN COMEBACK.
THINK ABOUT IT.
THEY ARE NOT BETTING ON MORE
LOCKDOWNS, THEY ARE BETTING ON
REOPENING AND RECOVERY HERE AT
THE WORLD IS MOVING ON.
YOU READ IT.
YOU FEEL IT.
YOU SENSE IT.
I UNDERSTAND THE MEDICAL
ESTABLISHMENT DOES NOT WANT US
TO MOVE ON.
THE MEDIA CERTAINLY DON’T WANT
US TO MOVE ON AND LIBERALS DO
NOT WANT US TO MOVE ON, BUT WE
ARE.
WE ARE MOVING ON.
I MAY NOT TAKE, YOU KNOW, AND
HAVE ALL THE TALENTS OF
ELON MUSK, BUT NO ONE SHOULD
DEPRIVE US OF OUR OWN RIGHTS TO
LAUNCH OUR OWN DREAMS, RAISE OUR